[Music]
hi guys welcome to my first ever life
workout I am so excited as a psycho yeah
I have Tracy here with me Tracy is one
of our few trainers so from this year
onwards I want to start introducing our
few trainers to you guys and you will
get to experience lots of different
types of workout from Bart
kickboxing yoga Pilates heat workouts
and more Tracy has been with us for the
past one year and Tracy does all sorts
of work out correctly yeah so booty bang
yeah Yoga Yoga today bar today is going
to be a really fun of bar workout it's
going to be a combination of dance and
fitness yeah and this is actually my
first time so yeah I'm nervous that's
true this is Joanna's very first bar
workout we have had no rehearsal but
what that means is it's probably your
first bar workout so what we aim to do
is introduce you to the fundamentals of
a bar class in case you've never done
one before
but I also like to throw in some really
good but no space cardio workout so that
you're gonna get your heart rate up
you're going to get sweaty that's kind
of the way we do things around here so
are we ready yeah so wherever you are
right now whether it's if the time
evening or in the morning let's have fun
and do this workout together I'm gonna
hand it over to Tracy oh you don't need
any equipment you'll see that we're
wearing these little bar top let got a
bit of a grip on the bottom you can use
your own you know trampoline tops if you
have those or bare feet is perfectly
fine so if you're still standing at home
and you're in your pajamas great okay so
we're gonna start by warming up the body
takes slightly wider than your hips and
your toes are at 11 and 1 bring your
arms up over your head we're just going
to drop down squat and swing your arms
back so we're gonna take each movement
for about 30 seconds and we're gonna
spin the next five minutes just warming
up your body before we hit the bar
you'll notice that we've got these
cheers on the side of her if you've got
a bookshelf nearby or you're standing
next to your so far you can use that
okay cool one one
all right hold up the air next we're
going to take a step tap and a spinal
twist so we're just releasing through
the lower back keep bending the knees so
you keep the legs nice and warm yeah
the arms are pretty relaxed just tuning
take your head with you yeah so you get
a nice stretch through the back of the
shoulders as well all right so we're
going to take each of these moves twice
through and a bit of a stretch at end
before we start focusing on out fast
specific movements all right we're gonna
take a running movement so we're going
running out and out of it at any pace
you like so if you're not ready to go
for us slow it down and kind of walk it
through it takes a little bit of agility
this one and it actually wakes up your
brain as well this is your morning
workout then you're probably thinking oh
oh here we go
I keep it coming awesome
five more seconds a little bit of heart
rate okay one of our first dance moves
here it's just a low kick okay so you're
just gonna kick the leg forward and I
like to kind of relax the arms as well
stretch your toes so you can get a
little tune out through the knees adding
that bar ballet flavor all right now
let's just add a little bit more Bend
but more legs into this how's that
feeling all right I know that's okay I'm
not trying to turn you into a ballet
dancer I think we just want to have fun
with this right not take it too
seriously
all right so let's go to the top so once
again reach up drop down and this time
you might want to add a little jump or
not if you're not ready for the jump try
adding a calf raise so we can warm up
through the carbs you'll notice with bar
workouts that they really do activate
the calf muscles so feel free to go
there now but when we hit the bar you'll
know all about it
your muscles will be ready all right so
squat tap a little twist I'm getting
warm hopefully you are too obviously you
know here in Malaysia it doesn't
I guess very long to warm up everything
is a pretty tropical that feels good
lakes are getting warm okay I think
Jonah likes the smooth coal candy yeah
all right we're gonna run the feet
afternoon here we go out and whatever
pace remember but what I want you to do
is think that we're nearly through our
warmup
so see if you can go just a little bit
quicker yeah keep it even keep the hips
level core engaged light on the feet
don't worry too much about the arms when
you think about the arms everything goes
a little bit crazy right so just focus
on the feet awesome three two and back
to that drop kick and swing okay so if
the kids are feeling good and your
hamstrings feel warm you can just lift a
little higher just reach that foot up a
little bit yeah hey we're in sync gold
just like a dance concert right I hope
you're not sitting on the cot on the
couch watching us yeah awesome all right
let's take a stretch reach up and
breathe whoo awesome and bring your
hands behind you and then open up your
kids that's it and they're just gonna
drop your head forward and bring your
arms back to us and if it's too much
release your hands to the floor we're
stretching out the back of the legs the
hamstrings and hopefully your body's
warm just give it a little shake let the
head relax and come on up
all right now what we're gonna do is
move to the bar and we've got a series
of poses and positions that we like to
engage so let me show you first what
we're going to do with the feet
I take fundamentally two ballet
positions okay so the first one is what
we call first
and that heels are together
the legs are straight and the toes are
facing the corner and you relax your
hand on your chair knock your bar on
your chair or your sofa or your
bookshelf or your kitchen bench right so
that's first second position the feet
are in the same angle so facing the
corners that wide okay that's really all
you need to know so come back to the bar
keep the heels together and then let's
just start with the arm out to the side
and these arms are called Porter bra
arms okay so they're going to be out to
the side for quite a while and you'll
start to feel a bit of shoulder heat if
you need to bring your hand down to your
hip okay so our first position at the
bar is we're going to take the single
piays so drop and lift so you press your
knees out and squeeze your inner thighs
to come up it's not really a fast
movement but we will progress this
movement so you'll start to feel the
legs a little bit more now don't
remember don't forget you can bring your
hands down right now lengthen through
your spine I'm going to introduce some
ballet style coaching tuck your pelvis
under keep your core engaged okay now
hold it down and pulse so press the
knees out yeah good
alright so what you start to notice is a
little bit of a heat through the front
part of your quad and we want that this
workout is predominantly lower body
strength okay so you're really going to
feel it in the legs and the glute
today that's what we want we want
beautiful tone legs alright hold on
alright so we're going to take it a
little bit further if this is enough for
you stay here otherwise lift your heels
keep the knees out and keep pulsing okay
we've just tuned up the heat or not yeah
I know this has happened because I can
feel it too every single time okay now
try to relax the hand that's on the bar
because you'll start to grip like that
keep pressing out good alright hang in
there we're going to progress a little
bit I'm shaking we're shaking we're now
going to go relevé so that means come up
and bend the knees but stay on the
so trying not to drop the heels your
option is to drop the heels and just
come up and down but I want you to stay
strong I think you can do this so we're
just going up and bend squeeze and Bend
nice good keep lengthening through the
top of your head you start to feel a
little bit of burn through your arm you
can bring it down okay but remember we
to tone the arms as well
okay next move release the heels you're
going to step wide and and so step out
to a wide plie and so it's second
position first position now let's bring
the arm in front here with a soft bend
in the elbow you are killing it you are
looking awesome she's having a ballet
lesson right now awesome
one more now we're going to take it out
and pulse it and bring the arm above
your head now anytime you take your arms
above your head what happens your heart
rate goes up now that is a battle in
your mind for what's happening to the
legs which is a major burn press the
knees out notice we're not even jumping
I love that we're not jumping but we're
feeling the heat okay hold it here now
you're going to hold it down and lift
your left heel drop right heel drop left
heel drop and just alternate like that
in your own time remember you can drop
the arm too if you want and bring it
down here so your arms are your own
expression of dance the legs do that
with us
alright so lift drop lift drop my heart
rates racing
when the Olivia okay now you're going to
lift the heel lift the arms impulse okay
this is like the clincher the finisher
here all right
woohoo keep pushing those knees out come
on just fifteen more seconds
oh hello we've got a wrist coming up so
hang on can you see how he's shaking
we're with you we are feeling this it's
live it's going down and release okay
but we're not jumping there's no jumping
it's all low-impact yeah it's good how
are you guys going do you know that
we've just done one side right so what
we going to do you can either turn
around or if you do have a cheer like us
you can just move it to the other side
because we've got the other side to go
so shake out those legs okay you did
really really well let's give it another
30 seconds or so just keep shaking
that's it stay relaxed if you want to
you can take a little quad stretch
because that's where I feel it like
right in the quads right yeah okay we're
going to balance up the quads in the
next section so that you can feel that
you're working all around the leg and
the glutes as well change okay getting
ready to start here we go so heels
together to the side and we go back to
the single plie so it feels like back to
the top from the beginning we're gonna
start running up that hill
so it kind of feels like I can equate
these movements to feeling like we're
going uphill okay everything gets
doodlee and progressively a little more
challenging but we can do it we got this
all right doing really well you ready
for those pulses you ready here we go
up the hill we go so remember you want
to keep this hand pretty relaxed you'll
notice that as things get progressively
more intense you start to kind of grip
like that all right I want to the chair
yeah upper body relaxed all the workers
in the lower body that's that good okay
we're gonna move on very soon where we
come up onto our heel onto our toes lift
your heels off the floor and stay with
the pulse are you ready three two one so
heels are up and pulse okay so you
really want to press your knees out to
the corner and drop your tailbone
straight down it's not a big movement
it's really activating into your medial
quads and external rotation of the hips
which tones the glutes all right so we
want that all right keep going nearly
there
okay we're gonna come out of it and give
those legs a bit of a straighten but I
want you to stay on your toes for the
releve so we go up and down now this
time just a little change of arm bring
your arm over your head so I want you to
think really tall really lengthen that's
one of the best benefits of Barre
workout everything feels strong and long
right yeah so you feel like oh I could
definitely do a New York Fashion Week
right now all right squeeze your inner
thighs let's set and then press those
knees out
nice work okay moving on so we're going
to go second and third second and then
it's taking a little first Bend as well
now remember we're gonna just change the
arms and bring them in front
hold it there shoulders away think
black swan --neck that beautiful ballet
movie those incredible athletes ballet
dancers like athletes right yeah they
are they're legit okay we're gonna hold
it here and just pulse bring the arm out
let's do something with the arms here so
let's drop them down let's bring them in
front let's take it up and let's take it
out now if that makes you hit go crazy
don't worry about that leave the arms
where they are down forward up and open
one more round down forward up and
they're going to hold it out to the side
and we're doing alternating heel lifts
okay let's push it out now it's that
good doing so well everyone all right
you'd be happy to know you're over
halfway through your bar life workout
with that I want you to hang in there
we've got some really really cool toning
and strengthening moves coming up for
your glutes and your hamstrings but
first we need to climb the top of this
hill so heels up pulse arms up arms up
booty down let's do it all right I know
what you're feeling I know what goes
through your head I've done this a few
times I just need you to hang in and
breathe oh my goodness Chris the boon is
real I didn't tell you about this part
and done shake it out
all right okay my legs are legitimately
shaking so I know what you might be
feeling at home
hey listen we've just got about five or
six minutes of work to go okay okay you
got a good suite on let's just turn the
cheer around so there because remember
this is Jonah's first time yeah so she
needs the fee what's happening here so
I can feel your yeah but you know what I
think I mean they say no pain no gain
and there's a little bit about work to
get the results that you want so as long
as you're having fun with it hopefully
you're having fun let's turn and face
your bar place your fingertips on the
bar we're going to focus on the glutes
and the hamstrings now okay
so just move a little bit further away
so your arms are nearly straight and
then bend your knees slightly okay so
we're going to do the first move you're
going to lift your left knee towards
your chest and then squeeze it straight
back behind you now so knee comes
forward straight back behind you you'll
find yourself naturally tilting forward
slightly and that's cool
I want that okay but I want the support
need to stay beat now you'll notice as
the lead goes behind you you should hit
the edge when your leg is straight and
you shouldn't be able to come any higher
so it really stays in line with your
spine okay now you're going to hold it
here and you're gonna tap down and lift
up tap down lift up then it's a tendency
to want to lean towards the support leg
so straighten yourself up keep your core
engaged try not to get too much
hyperflexion in the lower back and if
you can stretch your big toe so it's
your big toe that's touching the floor
and then point left tap left good so you
start to feel that squeeze in your
glutes alright we're going to take it up
a notch so hold it here and little
pulses pulse pulse pulse good okay so a
lot of these movements you probably
experienced in other types of exercise
classes but obviously and bar we hold
the bar and we try to extract through
our toes and give that sensation of
being the ballerina with long legs and
long muscles okay
we're nearly there so hold the leg here
now this time flex the foot and bring
the heel towards the glutes in extend so
it's a hamstring curl okay so you will
feel the squeeze of your muscle in the
back
your leg we've done a lot of work in the
front of the thighs so we need to
balance this out we got that nice ease
good keep the chest lifted relax the
elbows alright we're doing so well all
right hang in there
three two and I want you to hold the
last one bent and then pulse now just
slightly drop the chest and push the
heel up can you see the shaking in the
support leg that's because we've put the
muscles under quite a lot of pressure
already that support leg has had one big
contraction to hold our body still and
now we're pushing the limits is that
just me shaky okay holy moly
three two and release okay so you'll
feel it here and on the side yeah right
okay that's cool but if we lift you
there you'd be walking like this the
rest of the day so we're gonna change
legs
okay so shake it out and maybe just a
little hip stretch so press the hip back
the right hip back towards the right
corner yeah and get it ready
okay so home straight this is it so
relax your hands here we go again we're
gonna go right knee towards the chest
and then squeeze this is like a great
print move for all the other moves that
follow so it's just waking up the hip
getting that hip lever movement and
lengthening the back of the leg so when
you bring the knee in we're not we could
do it like a core move that we're going
to stay nice and straight today okay
just focusing on the thighs and we go
one more
now hold the leg long and you tap the
toe down and up and down and up all
right
I hope we're getting lots of thumbs up
and likes today maybe some actually
maybe some right there yeah this is
super fun yeah I love these workouts
because they're not high impact and I
can really feel the difference that's
really really good
okay hold it up baby pulps let's go
squeeze squeeze squeeze now any of the
moves that you pick up from today's
workout you can do any time most of them
are a hundred percent safe actually all
of them that I've tested yeah so you'll
be totally fine if you want to do this
workout alone or with a friend I
recommend with a friend oh my gosh you
are talking to me that sounds amazing
alright so we're gonna go heel to butt
and extends hamstring curl okay you've
got your last two exercises now this is
the part where it kind of you know a
kick zone and it gets a bit shaky where
your mind has to talk to your body and
to keep going good so you've got a
flexed foot there really squeeze into
that back thigh alright I'm the home
straight and hold it here and you've got
those donkey kicks so a little kick up
just a slight lean forward so we can get
more movement on the back of the leg in
the glutes and the hips and hang in
there all right we're going there whoa
keep breathing
I figured that anything that makes me
shake it must be working
it really works I can feel it the next
day but I'm happy about it it's good
three two one oh okay before we do
anything let's take a quick stretch here
just hang over the bar lift hip stretch
[Music]
yeah those legs Hey okay so let's just
move our cheer away and let's do a well
moon stretch
okay think yeah something that will help
you start or finish your day in the best
way so just start by stretching out long
through the body you did really well
yeah that was below and lower body there
wasn't a lot of up work was no upper
body except for holding your arms out
there okay now we're just gonna bring it
down forward lengthen the spine and if
you can fingertips to touch the floor
drop the head down and release through
your lower spine because a lot of the
movements that we did at the bar you can
sometimes feel your lower back muscles
contract quite strong so this is a good
way to release also into the back of the
legs all right from here let's just lean
forward slightly on the hands and take
the legs a little bit wider get into the
other thighs so the inner thighs work
quite hard when we're in that first and
second position anytime we're squeezing
into the other side hold it there
Embree
leave your right hand on the floor and
then just turn and face the left side so
you're getting a gentle twist through
the lower back cool and then change
sides
so place that left hand under your chest
right hand to the hip and then use the
left hand to leverage some twists
through the spine awesome hands to the
floor and then walk your feet together
grab your friend your partner your bar
if you want to we're going to do a hip
stretch so we'll hold hands here like
this for support and we're going to take
opposite legs and let me just really
hold on to you yeah there's a height
difference here and we're just gonna sit
back and hold on to each other in
stretch out the hips that was a really
good work yeah that's good doing it with
you if you're doing business read and
make sure to give them a high five okay
yeah it's always a lot more energy when
everyone else is right next to you okay
come up with change sides and sit back
haha a bit of balance training right
yeah and what a great way to start your
week as well yeah I'm just like sinking
into the stretch right now it feels so
good okay and then what last one little
quad stretch if you want to hold on to
something or you're feeling that your
core has got something to go over here
just a quad stretch draw the heel in
towards the hip press the knee towards
the floor and last stretch other side
all right
so I hope you enjoyed our workout this
is BA my loss Wow
okay I'll be able to hear that that's
awesome so I hope all of you at home
enjoyed this workout I hope you have
enjoyed having Tracy here as well thank
you sure to download if your app on
Google Play as well as the App Store and
you will be able to have access to more
workouts more programs as well as new
plants okay let us know in the comments
below if you would like to watch more
workout videos with Tracy and with my up
fear trainer yes
do remember to also give us a thumbs up
yeah and if you haven't yet subscribed
what are you waiting for subscribe to my
youtube channel and we will see you next
time yeah thanks guys see you next time
bye that was so good